Travis Scott's Netflix documentary look
mom I can fly just dropped and gives
fans an inside look at his home life
with Kylie Jenner and their one-year-old
daughter stormy now we are counting down
7 things we learned about the family
from the flick starting with this Travis
was right by Kylie side for her whole
pregnancy including all those doctor
visits
[Music]
Travis was so proud he even played a
recording of the heartbeat for friends
and when the couple welcomed stormy to
the world
Travis was on hand for the labor and
delivery he even cut the umbilical cord
[Music]
[Music]
and it seems stormy knew who her mom and
dad were right away she's on the table
right
soon she got boys as soon as I walked
away you start crying number two on our
list
wherever Travis goes Kylie and stormy go
to whether it was for his Astroworld
show in his hometown Houston Texas
[Applause]
[Music]
his sold-out show at Madison Square
Garden his Super Bowl halftime
performance or at the Grammy Awards
his leading ladies are his biggest fans
and while he might be one of music's
biggest stars at home he's still just a
regular dad buckling stormy into her
carseat dressing her flying her around
the living room getting her her first
pet dancing with her and buying her her
first Bentley okay so he's not a regular
dad he's a cool dad
he even danced it out with Kylie and
stormy at her first birthday party to
this hit track